der gestern gesagt deutschland will mich
draußen haben
warum denkt er dass das deutschland das
die deutschen ihn nicht haben wollen als
präsident man kann die zeitungen lesen
wir lesen auch die schlagzeilen meter
das höhere ziel den targa von unseren
deutschen kontakten und seit einigen
jahren haben wir das immer wieder gehört
ich höre das von freunden und bekannten
beständig auch ganzen namen noch mal
alle deutschen außerhalb berlins
sie hoffen dass donald trump gewinnen
möge aber die eliten die männer an der
macht der meinung diejenigen die eben
auch das sagen in der hauptstadt haben
all diese menschen scheinen wirklich was
gegen trump zu haben es geht hier aber
nicht so sehr um einen gegensatz
zwischen demokraten und republikanern
nein es geht um einen gegensatz zwischen
denen die mittendrin sitzen die an den
hebeln der macht sitzen und denen die
draußen sind donald trump ist keiner von
innen drin
von dieser macht elite er ist ein
geschäftsmann joe biden dagegen ist seit
47 jahren mitten in dieser macht wir
wissen eben von joe biden seine gesamte
vergangenheit hier insbesondere im
panzerwagen ja wissen die leute schon
mit wem sie es zu tun haben
am dienstag werden sie zur wahl gehen
und wir sind feste überzeugungen
präsenter deutschland da sind
er hat auch china erwähnt und iran das
eine ganz andere kategorie sollte da
deutschland damit dazu gehören
für deutschland ist das sind
gefährliches oder ein feindliches an für
ihn
nein wir sind natürlich weiterhin
verbündet das ist natürlich die große
enttäuschung für amerika
da es in europa einfach sich ist so und
so verhalten
die deutschen auf der straße die sind
doch dieser meinung dass deutschland
auch den angemessenen beitrag für die
nato leisten müsste finanziell die
größte volkswirtschaft in europa sollte
doch auch den angemessenen beitrag
leisten das ist aber nicht der fall
das ist wirklich eine enttäuschung und
auch eine gewisse verbitterung dieses
argument habe ich wohl tausend mal schon
angeführt als ich mich in berlin bewegt
aber der gedanke dass die größte
wirtschaft europas einfach nicht genug
zahlt was sie zahlen müsste das ist
tatsächlich eine art enttäuschung
insbesondere interessant
russlands ja es ist eben eine quelle von
enttäuschungen für viele amerikaner
sie haben da das gefühl dass deutschland
nicht an unserer seite steht
ich glaube hat sich sehr eingesetzt für
die transatlantische partnerschaft
er wollte wirklich dass diese
partnerschaft wirklich robust
unterfüttert wird es ist ja kein
geheimnis deutschland und andere haben
begonnen sich von diesen westlichen
werten zu entfernen
wir wollen natürlich europa und
deutschland als eine starke verlässliche
partnerschaft es sollte nicht alles
immer sehr lange dauern etwa wenn man
das